[Music]
we should have known that star wars
would eventually result in the downfall
of civilization through toxic fandom on
social media the second we saw that
opening of the first movie and it had
four dots in the ellipsis the signs were
all there from the beginning also
starting your star wars property with
this line but not going directly into
john williams incredible opening theme
in a nonsense positional text crawl
giving us this much of this lightsaber
battle without even the slightest hint
of any fates dueling in the background
score it's over anakin
i have the high ground look we all make
mistakes but including this in your
previously on the prequel sections
really feels like doubling down on what
is either a [ __ ] you to the abilities of
the jedi or a few to valid criticism i
actually kind of respect the latter and
there's nothing i like more than sinning
things i respect also i almost want to
remove a sin for disney giving us a four
minute recap to save us from having to
go back and re-watch three decidedly
average movies but it turns out even
this small snippet of a compilation was
enough to make me rageful about all the
missed opportunities and of course jar
jar binks
being a jedi and only just now realizing
your jedi yoga class is under attack
opening with the execution of order 66
is a super bold and dark way to start
the show and i'm kind of here for it
looks like this show's starting off
strong and really setting the tone for
what will surely be an action-packed and
well-paced series cindy's about to add
us in aren't they
what do we do now
we run don't worry you're safe you've
got plot armor what else would explain
why there are all of a sudden no backup
troopers on this bridge and still dozens
below also if this is the entirety of
the troop that stormed in here how were
these jedi overrun i'd put the average
jedi at least a 10 to one advantage on
troopers whose defining characteristic
is their incompetence there are at least
10 jedi in this giant room and at most
30 stormies star wars show starts on
tatooine cliche honestly at this point i
wouldn't be surprised if we spend most
of andor here too parking your ship in
the middle of the road scene does not
contain a jason isaacs you know
who we are i only mention in so that
you'll say it out loud so the audience
who didn't watch star wars rebels will
also know who we are oh and by the way
i'm following it up with a question
about what we do just so we can squeeze
as much forced exposition out of you as
possible now if you were smart he'd keep
moving but the jedi code is like an itch
i mean sure but you can hide an itch
look i'm just saying jedi can still do
good things under the radar and be
careful enough not to get caught you
don't have to be my cousin lance and
splay your legs and go crotch digging
every time you get an itch
there case in point uncut gems here
could have simply stopped that knife and
let it fall but for some reason decides
to control hover it there for a good
four seconds so that he can be spotted
here's an idea mr inquisitor sir instead
of force pushing the person you aren't
trying to apprehend and put them off
balance maybe force push the one that
you are
oh no however will they chase him
through these impenetrable rods in
fabric are jedi dumb now i feel like
jedi are dumb now also this somehow
works to deter them from giving full
chase is everyone dumb now i feel like
everyone's dumb now if you really want
to make the most of the shade provided
by this dead sand thing wouldn't
building along its side as close as
possible be a better option than
building outwards this makes even more
sense as we learn they're scavenging
food from it the fact that this slacker
still has a job look at him he's barely
moving the knife also this is the most
unsanitary meat processing plant to ever
on sanitary they're basically processing
meat directly from this erode kill in
the hot sun with sand everywhere and
this slacker isn't even wearing a hair
net
[Music]
considering we're about to find out this
greedy corporation cut the workers wages
in half without even telling them how
does this [ __ ] company pitching
pennies that tightly let obi-wan just
casually get away with pocketing a
portion of their daily output in plain
sight honestly it's not just that i'm
sick of this planet i'm sick of the way
every show on this planet thinks i want
to see more grandiose lawrence of
kenobia traveling sandborn so why
scholar once said i don't like sand it's
coarse and rough and irritating and star
wars cinematographers use it everywhere
ever since ray bubbled some up a few
years ago i've lamented that magic stew
isn't a real thing and now this show
continues that trauma by rubbing it in
my face after i'd almost gotten over it
either invent magic stew or take it out
of your content i can only handle so
much disappointment
i've been waiting 17 years to hear you
in mcgregor's obi-wan again and the
first thing you have him say is a
character tells another character
they're late even though it doesn't
impact the plot at all cliche if his
next line is you'd better come take a
look at this i'm shutting this channel
down do you have it
that was close man it's still pronoun
gaming so i do need to add another sin
here we see obi-wan buying the toy we'll
see luke playing with in the original
star wars which is cute and all but this
episode will pile on call back after
call back after wait call forward call
concurrent call it what you want when
you're doing it this much you're getting
us in tikka if you're going to steal my
parts and then sell them back to me
could you at least clean them first as a
courtesy jawas are deceitful little
thieves this is brand new information i
wonder if this is ground that's been
covered before in the movies the
mandalorian the book of boba fett the
video games the novels star wars rebels
star wars clone wars star wars streaming
and realistic and picture-perfect
flashbacks dreams aren't usually replay
videos their impressionistic surrealism
sleep theater with vague plot points at
the very least anakin should have hot
dog fingers just when you thought i
might be kidding about the sand porn the
show goes hardcore with yet another
desert travel montage if you listen
closely in the background you can hear
the dp moaning and ecstasy about grainy
beige and saying things like show me the
vast expanse of your badlands baby hobie
how's the peeping how's it peeping ov no
b.o.b.ob they're hunting me you have to
help me this whole interaction seems
silly to me why would nari seek out
obi-wan like this if he knew he was
being hunted what did he honestly think
obi-wan could do for him right now why
would obi-wan even stick around for this
conversation out in the open does no one
on this cloak and saber show know how to
clindestine correctly what about the
people that need us what about the fight
the fight is done
we lost as understandable as it is i
have to admit that moody mopey given up
on the galaxy kenobi is my least
favorite flavor of kenobi at least
they're getting the retired hero as
disillusion stuff out of the way so we
can see our beloved obi-wan swinging in
full force from episode two right
we're going to be late two character
accuses another character of being late
cliches in the span of 20 minutes that's
actually kind of impressive i hope the
rest of the show is just a series of
characters telling other characters
they're late until at the very end where
gandalf shows up precisely when he means
to she's either in the cellar in the
kitchen
or in the woods this must be the lamest
palace ever if these are the three best
options for a 10 year old to run off to
for fun also if leia's pulling this [ __ ]
so often wouldn't be smart to put some
sort of surreptitious tracking device
inside of her lola droid nah who am i
kidding i would be smart enough to do
that pleasure birds boring
i think star wars may have learned the
wrong lesson from the mandalorian since
baby yoda was such a hit now they want
to give us baby leia and then also give
baby leia a baby r2 i guess if they
think we overload on cute we won't
notice the terrible dialogue and plot
progression of this forced narrative
sorry sw we noticed it is like raising a
glory star wars character is insulted by
being compared to a creature that i've
never heard of therefore giving me no
context as to the nature of the insult
cliche no lola for the rest of the day
but she didn't do anything yeah well
neither did my pc when i got stuck
trying to be darth maul on the phantom
menace video game but that didn't stop
my mom for turning it off after three
days of not seeing me and saying
something about my night terrors keeping
her up i may have some unresolved issues
there if you behaved as well as you
climb
you'd be a senator already senators with
the maturity of a ten-year-old in other
words senators you know an episode of a
sci-fi show is paced poorly when i have
to wonder if i'm in a repeating time
loop story when the time comes he must
be trained like you trained his father
until this point it was generally
accepted that anakin was the recipient
of the worst burn in the franchise
also why is obi-wan so keen to train
luke but refuses to help the existing
jedi that are actually begging him for
help
no while we are here but i'll restate it
to you again in case the audience has
forgotten in the last 20 minutes since
we expositioned it to them the first
time
we're not under the empire
hear that split-second scream that's all
we're gonna hear from the now handless
backtalker for the rest of the scene we
won't see her hear her or have any idea
what happened after she got her entire
hand lasered off on one hand you might
think this is strange considering most
people who dramatically lose an
extremity would still be screaming in
severe pain somewhere but on the other
hand there is no other hand moses ingram
is great in this episode and i'm taking
off three sins just despite the racist
hateful morons who think that being a
fan means aggressively bullying anyone
who doesn't fit your shallow and
significant definition of the thing you
pretend to love grow up live love pursue
healthy fandom you troglodytes say
the scene would feel far tenser and
riva's threats would carry far more
weight if i didn't already know that
this character survives another show
falls victim to a bad case of prequel
itis we spent the last 10 years looking
for him
maybe you've been looking in the wrong
places well yes as evidenced by the
whole not finding him yet be careful
third sister the plot summary of most of
the episodes of the brady bunch somehow
makes it into the episode probably
scouring for pirates that's what i said
don't encourage her there are some
points in this episode where i swear the
writer's goal is to sound like every
trope from every bad sitcom in the
history of the galaxy we're really
playing the kid axe out but the dad's
into it and the mom has to play the
heavy and be the only adult in the room
card right now you don't need manners
when you're talking to a lower life form
then i guess i don't need manners when
i'm talking to you are we supposed to
side with leah here because we know she
turns out to be carrie fisher someday
because it could be argued she's being
the bigger nerf herder here he calls
into question her kindness towards
droids and she immediately goes full
force into a personal attack not even
adult kneeling to be on the same level
as a child for a heart-to-heart alert
automatic skip commencing one day this
planet will look to you leia and you
will look back to it well at least to
the remaining pieces you can still see
drifting off into space good talk why
are you here disney's incessant need for
extremely strange cameos just waiting
for what
for you
[Laughter]
that may be the lamest attempt at making
a chase seem real in the history of
filmmaking run the back in slow motion
will you not only does flea get caught
needlessly monologuing but watch this
guy he's there to catch this girl and
she gets a full five steps in before he
starts half-heartedly jogging after her
and you thought storm troopers were
idiots and it just keeps getting worse
as if the slow escape wasn't enough
watch again as these mercenaries
continue being bested by a
10 year old running through some light
foliage and pondering the complexities
of navigating a small tree branch
accompanied of course by a force load of
sins
[Applause]
[Music]
what about the senate
we cannot let this become public
it would draw too much attention well
then maybe leaving her with such an
influential family wasn't the best idea
to begin with you can't hide the
daughter of vader as the princess of an
entire planet and also complain that
telling the senate she's been kidnapped
will draw too much attention to who she
really is you can't have it both ways
fictional tv show i won't have it were
your guard then
or a bounty hunter only you know how
important she really is obi-wan isn't
that the beauty of bounty hunters the
whole point is they care much more about
the price attached to the bounty than
the bounty itself you pay them enough
and they bring you back leia and a basis
for your new cantina band you know an
episode of a sci-fi show is paced poorly
when i have to wonder if i'm in a
repeating time loop story and i find
myself reusing the same jokes also this
is the third time for this and yet the
show refuses to play any sunny and share
or go full whomp rad day sorry forgot
here on tatooine the artist is sunny and
sunny of course
children's toys that come equipped with
buzz saws honestly at this point just
rename the franchise star traversing
slowly through deserts in the occasional
wars you needed a shovel for something
buried less than a foot deep in the
loose sand not only could you have just
reached in there and grabbed that you're
lucky the wind didn't expose it within
the first few days of being under there
well
you're coming or not title of my star
wars sex tape
[Music]
casually flashing your lightsaber in
public when it could get you arrested or
even killed
do you not realize i have had diarrhea
since easter's
looking for this steamer
[Music]
what
all right
something you want to say
it's a sh dave affairs to be in tommy
and all the fresh air in the world won't
make any difference
[Music]
i had run for three years
two months
14 days and 16 hours
you're late a wizard is never
i'm a late who discovered the wheel and
built the eiffel tower out of metal and
brawn
you want my help
take this
and shove it up your ass all up in your
ass
i am asking you
to leave us alone ben i mean it
anybody wanna feel it i'm not afraid of
you you will be
you will be